[Music]
we all love solving riddles and pushing
the limits of logic this is why we want
to share with you the best riddles that
we found on the internet to play this
game you will have to pause this video
after every question so you will have
time to think before listening to the
answer make sure you watch this video
until the end if you want to try and
solve the riddle that is so difficult
that people named it after one of the
smartest men in the world if you love
riddles as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
ten mystery riddles that will blow your
mind can you solve them the psychopath
some people believe that only
Psychopaths know the answer to this
riddle this is why you should ask this
question to your friends to make sure
that you are safe when you were home
alone with them it all starts with a
girl who was at the funeral of her own
mother she met a guy that she didn't
know and thought that he was really cute
the girl believed that he was the love
of her life
and she immediately fell in love with
him but a tragedy happened one week
after when her sister was murdered who
do you think was the killer
make sure you pause this video to think
about this if you already know the
answer that's not a good sign are you
ready the stranger had nothing to do
with it the girl actually killed her
sister and the reason why she did this
was that she wanted to see that cute guy
again she didn't have time to ask for
his name or his phone number but she
thought that she would have the chance
to see him again at another funeral as
he knew her mother he probably knew her
sister too we just hope that the guy
knows how to run because you should
never date a dangerous woman like her
actually don't worry if you found the
answer it takes much more than a riddle
to be a psychopath hey guys we are so
excited to announce we are producing our
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
make a pact
much more we are sure you're going to
love it and be sure to let us know what
you think in the comment section we love
to hear from you the drink we just
wanted to have fun with the first riddle
but now let's start with an easy one two
girlfriends went to a bar and asks for a
drink
they both ordered an iced tea what if
the girls drank it really fast while the
other one took more time to enjoy her
drink but shortly after only one of them
was dead after she went to the hospital
people found out that she was poisoned
no one other than the barmaid touched
their drinks during that night and the
girl who survived says that she would
never kill her friends because she loved
her so much what do you think happened a
real detective wouldn't even have to
look at the cameras or analyze the
drinks to solve this case and we know
that you can do this too this is why we
want you to take the time that you need
to think about this do you have an
answer great let's hear the truth about
this story the poison was actually in
the ice the first girl drink her iced
tea really fast so it didn't have time
to melt but the other girl took her time
so the poison was released in the drink
the story doesn't tell why someone would
put poison in the ice but we think that
they could possibly be Psychopaths too
the suicide after watching this video
you will become a real detective and to
practice we have another riddle for you
if you watch TV series you know that
killers often make a murder look like a
suicide
this is what happened in that case
police officers found a dead man with a
cassette recorder in one hand and a gun
in the other they pressed the play
button on the cassette and heard the man
saying that he had nothing else to live
for and that he couldn't do this anymore
then we heard the gunshot in the
recording after listening to this the
detective immediately knew that it was
not a suicide but that someone else
actually killed the man so this case is
solved but we want you to tell us why
they knew that it was a murder
we'll let you think about it for a
moment if we can give you only one clue
it's that the older people will probably
think that it's easier to solve this
riddle did you get X if not we'll tell
you the answer
the detective knew it was a murder
because when he pressed the play button
he immediately listened to the recording
it seems that someone had the time to
rewind the cassette tape which would be
impossible if the man was dead that was
a hard one but we loved the answer the
murder are you ready to solve another
crime we think that you'll have the
skills that it takes to solve this
murder detective it all starts for the
rich man who was found dead in his home
on a Sunday morning his wife immediately
called the police and a detective came
to the house to investigate he asked
questions to the wife and all the people
who worked there they all had alibis the
wife said that she was sleeping when it
happened
the butler said that he was cleaning the
house the gardener was picking up some
vegetables the maid was getting the mail
and the clip was preparing the breakfast
when we heard this the detective
immediately knew who the killer was
can you find out who is lying we'll give
you some time to think about this you
might think that you don't have enough
information but when you hear the answer
you'll know that it was actually really
easy are you ready one of the alibis
doesn't make
and the information that you needed was
actually at the beginning of the story
the maze said that she was getting the
mail but everyone knows that the mail is
not delivered on Sunday it means that
she was the liar if you ever try to kill
someone at least try to think about a
better story actually just don't commit
a crime please the crime scene
things are getting that little dark but
this one is going to be our last crime
and you need to get the answer if you
want to prove that you are a true
detective it all starts with a man who
murdered his wife in his car in the
middle of nowhere he threw the body out
of the car while making sure that he
left no fingerprints he hid the weapon
where he knew that no one would find it
and he made sure that no one would see
him then he took his car and went back
home shortly after the police called him
to say that his wife was murdered and
that he needed to join them at the crime
scene the man wanted to make sure that
he looks like a husband who cared for
his wife so he said that he would be
there and immediately hung up to go
there as fast as possible but when he
arrived at the crime scene he was
immediately arrested how did I know he
was the murderer
we'll let you think about that for a
moment the reason why the police
officers knew that the husband was the
murderer is that he didn't even ask
where the crime scene was when they saw
that he came to the right place
they knew that they needed to arrest him
we loved that riddle the bridge we don't
want to kill any more people for the
rest of the video so let's try another
kind of riddle this time you will need
to be good at math but don't worry it is
mostly about logic Aiden Brandon
Charlotte and Dave had to cross to the
old wooden bridge at night the bridge is
so weak that it can only carry two
people at the same time and they have to
stay together they also need to carry a
flashlight on each crossing but they
only have one so they will have to come
back with it to give it to the others
they have different fitness levels so
Aiden can cross the bridge in one minute
Brandon can cross the bridge in two
minutes
Charlotte in five minutes and Dave in
ten minutes
Aiden the leader of the group thinks
about this and says that they can cross
the bridge in 17 minutes how are they
going to do that
this time we think that you will really
need to stop the video to think about
this even if you are really smart do you
want the answer
here it is Aiden will have to cross the
bridge with Brandon then he comes back
with the flashlight Charlotte and Dave
crossed the bridge together then Brandon
who was already waiting on the other
side comes back with the flashlight to
give to Aiden then the two come back
together did you figure that out it was
a hard one the stranger this one is a
little scary and this is why we love it
but don't worry no one ends up dead this
time it is a short story of a woman
sitting alone in her hotel room she
hears a knock at the door she answers
without opening the door and sees a man
that she has never seen before
through the people he says that he is
sorry because he thought that it was his
room he then goes down the hallway and
takes the elevator as soon as he is gone
the woman immediately calls the security
but why did she do that
most people would think that the man was
simply a little lost so why was she
scared of him we'll give you some time
to think about this weird story before
we reveal the answer are you ready okay
let's go the reason why the woman called
the security is that the man lied to her
no one knocks at their own hotel room
door if he tried to open it it would be
another story but knocking at the door
just doesn't make sense we think that
this man realized that the woman wasn't
going to be a good victim when she
refused to open the door that's why he
gave up and that's also why you should
never open the door to a stranger the
suspects this time we already caught the
suspect and we have to find out if he is
guilty or not this is what happens in
court this man was accused of killing
his wife but no one really knew if he
did it or not this is why the man's
lawyer decided to surprise everyone to
make sure that he was going to win the
case he said that the wife actually just
disappeared and she was going to come
out of the door in 30 seconds people
turned to the doors and they waited for
a few minutes while the defendants
stared at the jury the wife didn't come
but the lawyer said that if they were
sure that
man killed his wife no one would have
looked at the door and the husband can't
go to jail if they are not sure that he
is the murderer
but the jury immediately decided that he
was guilty anyway do you know why we'll
give you some time to figure out the
answer or you can also stop the video
and there we go
they understood that the husband was the
murderer because he was the only one who
didn't look at the door he knew that his
wife would never come back because he
killed her we think that the judge would
make a really good detective the
prisoner what happened when you commit a
crime you have to go to prison
however this man was not guilty and he
wanted to escape to avoid the death
penalty this is why we need to help him
because he only has a few minutes left
to live there are two guards in front of
him one of them tells him that if he
tells the truth he is going to be hanged
the other says that if he lies he is
going to die in the electric chair
the man can only make one statement what
can he say to survive we'll let you have
some time to think about this one
but don't worry that you have to think
fast because this is a matter of life
and death don't be too stressed either
because it won't help you so let's just
stop the video for a moment now are you
ready to get the answer the only thing
that the man has to say is that he will
die in the electric chair if it is the
truth he should actually be hanged so it
won't work and if it's a lie he should
die in the electric chair
but the statement wouldn't be a lie
anymore this is why being the smartest
is actually better than being the
strongest did you get this one
Einstein's riddle and last but not least
is the famous Einstein riddle you will
need a piece of paper for this one
because it is really complicated there
are five houses in five different colors
in a row a person with a different
nationality lives in each house and they
drink a certain type of beverage smoke a
certain brand of cigar and keep a
certain pet you will have access to 15
facts to solve this riddle the BRIT
lives in the red house the Swede keeps
dogs as pets the Dame drinks tea the
green house is on the emedia
left of the white house the green houses
owner drinks coffee the owner who smokes
Pall Mall rears Birds the owner of the
yellow house smokes Dunhill the owner
living in the center house drinks milk
the Norwegian lives in the first house
the owner who smokes blends lives next
to the one who keeps cats the owner who
keeps the horse lives next to the one
who smokes Dunhill the owner who smokes
blue masters drinks beer the German
smokes Prince the Norwegian lives next
to the blue house the owner who smokes
blends lives next to the one who drinks
water who owns the fish we won't give
you the answer this time but we want you
to write it in the comment section down
below let's see who is smarter than
Einstein and that's it for 10 mystery
riddles that will blow your mind for
more spooky stories like this make sure
you watch 10 epic kids costume ideas for
Halloween thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]